The fire department presentations. Reminder to council members you
should submit any department budget workshop questions in a word document
and upload it to SharePoint budget workspace.
Departments have been directed to provide responses within 48 hours
of the conclusion of their presentations. Department responses will
also be uploaded to SharePoint. We will now hear from Chief Pena,
who will provide the fire Department budget. Chief floor is yours.
Thank you, Mr. Vice Chair. First of all, I want
to thank you. I want to thank the committee members for allowing me to
present the Houston Fire Department's proposed fiscal year 2023
budget. Before I begin, I'd like to acknowledge some of
my civilian staff and of course, my command staff for
the assistance that they provided in preparing this budget. With me.
I have the Houston Fire Department's department fiscal
administrator, Ms. Rochelle McHenry. I also have members
of my command staff here. Chief west and Chief McLeod are joining
us. But the thanks
goes to all our staff who really have been
doing tremendous work. I also want to acknowledge and thank Mayor
Turner and this council for giving me the support this year and the finances
to provide the needs for this
organization. The Houston Fire Department is
the third largest municipal fire department, protecting the fourth
largest city in the country. And my hat
goes off to the men and women of the Houston Fire Department for the incredible
work that they do each and every day. It's an active system,
just like any major city. We run about 344,000
calls for service each year. We're still dealing with
the effects of the pandemic and working
through some very challenging times. But I cannot say enough about the work that the
men and women of the Houston Fire Department do to ensure the safety of this
community. So very proud of the work that they do.
First slide, please.
So the proposed fiscal year 2023 budget for the
Houston Fire Department is $559,000,000.
This will be funding 3933.3
FTEs in six funds. The distribution of the funds and
the personnel are displayed here in six key areas.
And as you can see, the major funding is for personnel
that is allocated to the emergency response program. Next slide.
Our primary function and mission is the protection of lives and property
of our residents. Our goal is to accomplish this primarily through
prevention, code enforcement and investigations. But we do
spend a lot of money to train and prepare for responses to emergency
medical calls, fire calls, hazmat,
technical rescue, aircraft rescue, and a variety of other
programs. Next slide.
The legal provisions that guide our agency and approve
programs and services for our department are listed here on this slide.
I do want to highlight the last bullet point in the anticipation of
increased demand in service for our department.
This is particularly going to be in the area of emergency medical services.
The population growth, and especially the aging population will drive
up the need for our services. The same thing will occur with
the aging infrastructure as it relates to fire response.
So it is critical, and it's more important now more than
ever that we maintain focus of adopting
appropriate fire codes and enforcement tools to maintain
the desired quality of life here in the city. Next slide, please.
So, as we move on to the financials of our presentation, this first slide
summarizes the department's revenue projections for the general fund.
In fiscal year 23, we're projecting a slight increase in the
majority of our regular operating revenue streams.
This is going to be offset by a larger decrease in three
specific revenue accounts. So the overall net effect
for our revenues is a decrease of 7.73%,
or $8.9 million, from fiscal year 22 to fiscal year
23. For our department, the revenue
is derived primarily from licensings and permits intergovernmental
revenue. This is in
addition to charges for services or ambulance transports.
Direct inner funds. This is the money that we receive from Haas for personnel
assigned to the airport stations. The miscellaneous
item, the category, is primarily the reimbursement
for our special operations teams and their deployments.
So licenses and permits are essentially flat.
This year is our projection with a slight increase in the expected fire permit revenue.
We're also projecting a 39% reduction in the
intergovernmental category due to an increase primarily to
the amount of money we're going to receive from the ambulance supplemental
payment program. And I'll explain more in a later slide.
The charges for service increase is primarily due to the
expected increase in Hazmat permits, which will bring us back to the pre pandemic
revenue figures. This is going to be offset against a
decrease in cell phone revenue towers. This is
the lease money that we get from Verizon for allowing them to
put their cell towers on the fire stations.
In the direct interfund services, this is the chargeback
for Haas. Again, for airport firefighters, the change
reflects a 6% base pay raise offset
against a lower pension rate for this account,
for other fines and forfeits the amount from fiscal year
22 is essentially flat. In the miscellaneous
and other categories, the change from budget to estimate is a decrease
of ten point 43%.
This is going to be primarily due to an expected decrease in the natural disaster
reimbursement. Again, for for deployments in fiscal year 21
and 22, the tactical deployment of
the Texas Task Force One members. They were deployed
higher than normal, and we don't expect the same number of
deployments this fiscal year. In other resources, we captured
the revenue associated with the Enterprise Light duty lease program
for our light duty vehicles, and I have a slide that will
go more in depth a little bit later. So again,
the fiscal year 23 projection revenue of $107.4
million is approximately 7.73% less
than fiscal year 2022s. Again, I want
to stress the point that this is mainly due to the ambulance supplemental payment program
which will be reduced, and I'll explain more on this. Next slide,
please. So,
as mentioned, the supplemental reimbursement program is expected
to drop by about $9.5 million.
This fund provides for the reimbursement for care, for Medicaid
and indigent care patients. So as of October 1,
2019, the uncompensated care program transitioned
to a charity care pool. This change eliminated
the Medicaid shortfall supplemental program,
and it redefined it as an uninsured cost to charity
care cost. Okay. That's the significant change.
This required agencies to
have a charity care policy in place. The first
year, very few providers were able to get that policy in place.
The Houston Fire Department. The City of Houston actually did. So we were one
of the few participants in the pool. This second year,
more providers are able to have that policy in place.
So we have more agencies competing with
the same pool. So the number
of dollars in the pool did not increase, but the number of participants
did. So the disbursement was a little less to every
provider. That's essentially the high level explanation on
why we're getting a lower return this year. Next slide,
please.
Okay. This is the Vehicle Lease
program. So this program has allowed us to do a wholesale
replacement of our vehicles, the light duty vehicles, primarily in
the Life Safety Bureau, and we are in
the first replacement cycle for that program.
The program we incorporated 105 vehicles in the
lease program this year.
We were supposed to sell that one year old vehicle,
105 of them, and get new vehicles. The money that was
realized from that sale was going to go back reprogrammed
into the program. Because of supply chain issues, we were
only able to sell 49 vehicles. So,
as you can see, the disbursement was $563,000
for those vehicles. Enterprise what they did is they gave
us 65% of the equity
in those vehicles. They paid it out this year for next
fiscal year, we will sell again those 49
one year old vehicles, plus 56 vehicles that now will
be two years old. And we'll realize only the 35% equity
that was left over. That's the reason for the change
in the revenue. But essentially, as you
can see, the first year we realized,
to the benefit of the city is $391,000.
We replaced 105 vehicles. The program really,
it was essentially cost neutral. Matter of fact, the city
was reimbursed an additional 395 or $91,000
fiscal year 23. Our projection is going to be about half
of that. Again, because of the explanation that I gave earlier, we're selling
two euro vehicles instead of €1 vehicles. After this year,
we will be back on track to sell, replace 105,
and sell 105 every year. Next slide.
These are expenditures by funds. The proposed expenditure target for
fiscal year 23 is $559,000,000,
which represents an increase of 20.3 million from
the current budget of $538.7 million.
The increase by category and personnel cost
is a net of several increases including civilian and
classified base and related fringes, as well as
classified overtime and classified health. This will be offset against a decrease
in the classified pension and classified workers
comp cost. A 10.9% increase
in supplies is due to an increase in cost of doing business,
primarily in drugs, medical surgical supplies,
as well as a small increase for the GL account for the
fifth Academy class that we were approved for this
coming fiscal year. Contributing to the overall 3.77%
growth is an increase in our restricted accounts of eleven point
61%. This is the Interfund chargeback accounts for
It for HR, fuel and fleet services.
And lastly, an increase in our service account of $958,000
is a transfer of funds from GST for the payment of our
lease for our building, for our headquarters.
This is in addition to that, it's an increase in other inner
fund services for payments of It service personnel.
Contractual increases which will be offset again by a decreasing
in billing and collection expenditure from our
medical biller because of the reduced amount in the
ASPP fund, the ambulance supplemental plan.
The equipment fund change is due to not requiring us
to invest this year for items that were purchased in fiscal
year 21 and 22. In 21 we purchased some surface
pro tablets, some related equipment, some desktops and
three thermal imagers. In fiscal year 22, those expenditures
were directed towards extrication equipment, jobs of life
and those types of equipment. We will not have to make that purchase
this year. That's the reason for the change.
As far as the explanation for the Debt services fund, in fiscal
year 21, $53,000 was transferred from Fund 1000 to
Fund 40 515. This was done for the
purchase of drone equipment for our tactical deployment team.
We ran out of time actually to get that purchase done before the
end of the fiscal year. So we did receive approval to transfer
the funds that were allocated from District G's
service funds to
Fund 40 515. That way we wouldn't lose that budget. That's the
explanation for that. Next slide please. So this
is how our funds are allocated. Of the fiscal year 23
budget, 88% is allocated to Personnel services.
This leaves a total operating budget of $69.5
million, of which 63% or
45 point or $43.5 million is
in restricted accounts. This is for HR.
Interfunds fleet interfunds and so on.
17% is in the other category. This is for
certain contracts, our telemetry contract and other service
contracts. 6% is allocated for our billing
and collections agency, which leaves
us approximately $10.2 million annually to cover
medical supplies, to cover personal protective equipment,
firefighting equipment and other supplies needed for the operation of
this organization. Next slide please.
So this slide walks us through the changes from fiscal year 22 current
budget to fiscal year 2023 proposed budget. Our fiscal
year 22 current budget is $538.7 million,
of which 36.8 million is in restricted accounts.
The 22 current budget figure of 538
is a net adjustment for fiscal year 22.
Hope contractual adjustments. It includes restricted accounts
increases of $2.2 million, some health benefit
returns of $3.8 million, and a city council surplus
dollars of $29,000. Other operating contractual adjustments
of 4.7 million includes one time adjustments for
workers compensation increases, overtime expenditures,
which are then offset by classified and cadet vacancy savings.
So the total adjustment, the one time adjustment for this is
$3.3 million. So to go from 22 to
23 budget, we have incremental increases and decreases in operating
and contractually mandated expenses.
And I'll explain here. So coming back into the budget is
$2.75 million for our fifth academy class that was approved
funding for a 6% across the board pay raise
for classified personnel, other classified adjustments of $2.4
million for base overtime, a return
of the council surplus dollars, and a reversal of the one time operating adjustments
for a total of three. I'm sorry. $21.3 million in
adjustments or a 4.26 increase from
FY 22 to FY 23.
The contractual obligations include the following hope
obligations contractual obligations adjustments for
civilian and classified health, civilian and classified pension and FICA
and other funding or restricted accounts,
contract, Escalations, and other contractual adjustments. So the subtotal
of contractual obligations is -920 $6,000,
which is largely the result of savings related to the reduction in the classified pension
rate, the operating contractual obligation
adjustments of $20.3 million, which takes us to our fiscal
year 23 proposed budget of $559,000,000,
or a 3.77% increase from 20. Two's current
budget. Next slide,
please. So,
these are the highlights of the materials we just covered. Of additional
focus, I'd like to mention the five non certified
cadet training classes for a total of 350 new hires
for fiscal year 23, and the cost associated
for the continuation of three non certified classes,
which were begun this fiscal year.
In addition to that is a grant match for the AFG grant
to provide training and physicals with cancer screenings
for firefighters and also the completion of our vehicle exhaust installation.
That grant matches approximately $309,000.
And then
we discussed the other ones already. So next slide, please.
That is my presentation vice Chair. I am open for any questions.
Thank you, Chief, for your presentation, I'm going to start with questions from Council member
Abby Cayman. Thank you so much, Vice Chair.
Chief, thank you for not only to you, to your
executive team command all the way on down. It's a privilege
to work with you all. Thank you. Few quick questions. As I said,
I'm asking this of every department.
Given the budgetary and financial constraints that the city continues
to face due to revenue limitations,
what can we not afford right now
that's needed? That's not to say that mayor and
council is not trying to approve everything that we can, but there are significant
large budget items that are necessary that we, quite frankly, can't afford.
Such as I'll say it, and I know council Member Peck will probably
raise it. CAD I'm looking back in the appendix
diesel exhaust removal for some of our stations.
Are there other things that we need to be
talking about that we cannot necessarily afford right
now? Council Member the answer to that question
is definitely a yes. You mentioned technology is
a critical need for our organization. The computer aided
dispatcher CAD system needs complete replacement
on that. We're working with almost a 20 year old system, and there are
a lot of things that we could be doing to create efficiencies within the
organization that are not possible because of the age of that
program. One of them is dispatching by location,
vehicle location, text to 911.
All those priority dispatch systems,
all those things that we can explore are
a little bit more difficult because of the age of that system. So technology is
one of them. The other needs are going to be primarily focused on training
and professional development for the members of the organization.
An increase in service capacity, primarily ambulance
and transport service capacity is what we need,
and there are a lot of needs for upgrades
in our facilities.
I need you to put me back in queue. I had one more question.
You have one more. Go ahead. Okay, thank you. And again, Chief, I do want
to congratulate you on in the department on the things you have accomplished.
Again, going back to the appendix, the increase
in pay, the Hazmat units,
the following up on 100% of
cardiac arrest incidents, adoption of the fire code,
the lease vehicle program.
There's a lot in here that is absolutely
to be commended for. I do want to point out I continue when
we look at the comparative gender and ethnicity statistics,
the very low level in terms of classified of
female employees. Yes. And that's it, I think
3.85% compared to 96.15%
in the largest population of
HFD employees. So I would just bring our attention to
that. In terms of recruitment, I know that there are recruitment challenges that we
continue to face, but I know that we
are striving to be as diverse as possible, and I see that reflected
in Y'all's efforts. But I just wanted to point that out that
we have more work to do there. And if you could really quickly touch base
on you kind of touched on it, but our inspection
capacity and our ambulance transport
capacity I know you just mentioned it, but inspection
capacity seems to be a pretty big need.
Yes, ma'am. Look, if we focus all our
attention and resources on just the emergency response,
we're never going to be able to keep up with demand. We're going to make
the biggest impact in our call volume and demand
if we prevent things from happening.
That speaks to our need to provide more inspections
for these commercial businesses. Having more inspectors
to ensure that the codes, when we're building, we're building appropriately
and up to code and having those eyes on scene to ensure that
we are meeting those codes because it's going to assist us downstream
in not having to respond to so many fires or major fires.
The same thing goes for medical response.
25% of our basic life support calls are
people that call more than once or twice per year.
Okay? And what we found is that those individuals don't
need the most expensive taxi to go to the most expensive part
of the Er. They need access to the right social service. Right. We have that
information. It's having resources to
focus on those social services and
making those connections with existing agencies that's going to
allow us to make a definite impact on the number of calls
that come in from repeat customers. Let me say it that way.
So certainly inspectors and then we
know that we have an increase in population and increase in aging population
and whether we like it or not, we are the medical safety
net for this community. So emergency medical transport
and ambulance service is what we need to focus on right now.
We're limited in our ability to increase that because of our staffing
situation. But strategically that's something that
we've discussed with the mayor and administration. The mayor is completely supportive
of doing that. We just need to fix the
staffing issue first and then we can move forward.
Chief, when looking at your presentation,
can correct me if I'm wrong, but it seems that you had an increase
in expenditures but a decrease in revenues.
Yes. What creative ways can we increase revenues
within the department? Other ways to increase revenues in
the department of course. Look, the major
revenue source is our charge for service and primarily
ambulance service.
We brought forth a recommendation for an ordinance,
an increase in the charge a couple of years ago.
That recommendation was based on data
that was already a couple of years old at that time.
Since then we've had an increase of 6%
pay raise last year. We are going to have
a 6% increase this coming year. And so the cost
of delivering service has gone up not only in personnel cost but
also the cost of supplies and materials.
In one particular drug that we use the
cost went up almost 90%. Right. And so everything
is going up. We are not recovering
what it cost us to deliver. So we need to another analysis, another study
to see what that rate would be. Second thing is
our payer mix is heavy medicare, Medicaid in
this community. And then we have a large percentage of self
pay which means no insurance. So our collection rate is about 39%
to 40%.
At some point medicare or Medicaid is expanded.
We would have the ability to collect
more. Increasing the rate of
service cost or the charge
for service would be one way because medicare and Medicaid they reimbursed
at the usual and customary rate. We are
the big elephant in the room.
We are the largest ambulance provider in this region,
so if we keep our rates arbitrarily low,
there is no incentive for that reimbursement
for Medicare, Medicaid to be adjusted upward. So we have
to look at some of these things. I know it's a difficult conversation,
but again, the that is our
primary service provide or service
that we provide, where we get reimbursement from when
looking at other large cities around the country, how are we
as it relates to competitive salaries?
Well, look, all I can base it on is what we provide,
what we presented a year ago.
And that was based on a total comp study for
pay. And we were below the average,
about 18%. The mayor and council
approved us to increase the pay rate by
18% to try to help us get up to at least the median.
But every year,
the new contracts in other areas go up. There is
incentives and pay increases that happen. And so
we have to have a strategy to
be competitive.
Council member Amy Pitt. Thank you. And thank
you, Chief, for the presentation. You talked about
equipment purchased last year that we don't have to purchase this
year, and that's why that line item went down. Can you talk a little bit
about what's in the budget for just regular equipment,
like normal wear and tear, aging equipment, also equipment that's
stolen, like it was just stolen on engine four the other day,
that kind of thing? Yes.
I want to say it's unfortunate, but shrinkage is something that we experience as
well here in the department several times.
That was the most recent one. But we do experience
theft oftentimes. A lot of times it's our employees
who are the victims of that. At the fire stations, they have
their vehicles broken into. We do have monies
allocated council members for the MNO of our equipment.
Every year we try to anticipate a certain number of replacement.
We've taken a different approach in the last five years, starting from the
big ticket items like our apparatus.
We've gotten to the point where we are almost on
schedule to replace every one of our apparatus every ten years.
And so again, council and mayor, you all
have made a significant investment in allowing us
to get that plan implemented. But we've
taken the same approach for everything in our inventory.
Everything has a shelf life. Everything has a total life expectancy.
It needs to be replaced. It's easier to replace and take small bites
at the apple every year than to wait until we have to make wholesale replacements.
It's very hard to budget that way. So to answer your question is yes,
we do have a replacement plan for every
one of our items that we have in our inventory.
Great. Thank you. The Vehicle Lease program.
I love this program. Are we planning on expanding that past
the 105 vehicles? Yes. The answer is yes.
Our hope is that we're going to include all the arson vehicles and eventually
all the light duty vehicles. We're also
looking, and I'm working with staff to see if we can lease
the heavy apparatus for those stations that are
slowest in call volume.
So the plan is to take those apparatus,
take them off the board on the replacement plan, and put them into a lease
program until we can make some significant improvements
on the existing on the remaining ones, and then put them back into
slowly fold them back into the replacement plan.
One of the latest projections
was that I can get ten vehicles for a
million dollars a year on a lease, ten apparatus.
And it would mean moving from CIP funding
to operating funds. But I think that's a
I mean, that's a proper use of government funds of city
resources because it allows us to have one serviceable
equipment and two at a lower cost per year.
And so, yes, I'd like to expand it. The program
that we have in place now, I think the proof of concept
is that it works. As I
mentioned, at worst, we break even. But we have
brand new vehicles, one year old vehicles every year. And that not
only increases our efficiencies, but it improves morale.
We were running around with 1520 year old vehicles. A lot
of them didn't even have the latest safety equipment. So this
is a good program. I think it's good government. I think it's
a responsible way of using city resources, and I'm hoping
to expand this program. Great. Thank you, chief and vice chair. If you
could put me back in the queue of another question. Thank you.
Go ahead. My last question is,
is there anything that we should be funding for insurance or
accreditation reasons that we are not funding in this proposed
budget?
Okay, I'm not understanding your question. I know that
there are certain things that we're supposed to like programs,
numbers, that kind of thing that we're supposed to be doing every year. Is there
something in the unmet needs that we should be doing? I mean,
I know that everything is a need, but something that we could lose some kind
of accreditation or insurance purposes that we should be
funding that we're not? Well, look,
we just got our ISO rating
for the city of Houston and the Houston Fire Department. It came
back as an ISO one, which is the highest level you can get.
We just received our accreditation from the Commission on Fire Accreditation
International.
We've met the requirements for those. But we do have
to be looking at the increase in call volume and
what we're going to do about that. One of the things that we need is
additional transport units. And I've mentioned this before, not only
in this budget presentation, but in other committee presentations.
We need more ambulances. Our response times for
those call volume or those call types is going to increase.
I don't know that we're at risk of losing any certification
or accreditation for that. But we certainly at some
point, if we don't make a strategic effort to address
that, we won't be meeting the needs that the community is
expecting. And so increasing ambulance
capacity is one of the main things that we need to be looking at
inspections is another one. We need more inspectors.
Again, the biggest impact we're going to make is in the prevention side,
not on the response side. So to do that, we need inspectors.
We'll now move into the public comment period of the hearing.
We have three virtual public speakers,
and the first one is Saba Blanding. Please press
star six to unmute. Saba Blanding.
Okay, yeah, you think I have this down
by now, but still a struggle.
Chief, you really actually already answered my first question,
but I'm going to ask it in case you wanted to expand.
And that was what do you need in order to better provide preventative
services? You mentioned increasing inspectors, and I was
also curious in regards to that, if it's primarily an issue
of staffing or training or both, and if there was any other
needs you all had. And then along with that,
I'm curious, what preventative measures do you think the city
could take beyond what it currently exists to reduce the demand
on your department on the response side? And I really appreciate you
bringing up the importance of prevention. So that's my primary
question. Thank you. Okay,
so in regards to the inspectors question, it's both
It's personnel and It's. Training in order to do fire inspections.
The Texas Commission on Fire Protection requires a certification
as a state inspector, and so that takes a little while
to train people up, but first we need personnel.
It's a combination of both. In regards
to what would help in
stemming the increased call volume. I think the
more a concerted effort
in a public safety message on the proper use of 911,
we have a lot of calls that
don't qualify as emergencies,
but people still use the 911 system for
things that really could be handled in a different way. So I
think we have some work to do in
providing information, providing a
better way of communicating how to properly use
the 911 system because it's a busy system. As I mentioned,
we run close to 350,000 calls for service
every year, and that's just us. The 911
center receives a couple of million calls.
I'm not exactly sure what the number is, but for both police
and fire at the 911 center, and a
certain percentage of those calls wouldn't really qualify
as emergency, but we still have to respond to them,
and so that would be one
way to do that. Thank you. Our next
virtual speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver.
Please press star six to unmute.
Hi, Chief.
I wanted to follow up on something you mentioned about pay.
You said that the 18% will bring.
US up to the average from last
year. Right. So any raises
that departments or comparison departments have made last
year or this year or next year. Right. When we get
to the 18%, they'll be at 25
or 30%. Well, maybe not that far, but they'll be
significantly beyond whatever we end up at.
Is that correct? I do know, Mr.
Oliver, that the city of Houston is commissioning a comp
study for this year. It should be ready sometime
this year, and we'll have a
better target of where we stand in comparison to our
counterparts in our industry.
The 18% was much needed,
and it's a huge step in the right direction. I will wait for
the comp study to come up sometime this
year, and then we will make the case for additional pay raises
for our firefighters. But, look, it's retention and
recruitment is a practical concern for me.
We have to be competitive in our industry to maintain
the talent that we have here on the department. It costs us a lot of
money to train and recruit, and we want them to remain
on this department. So one way to do that is to
ensure that we're competitive in pay. And then one
last question about I know the
emergency center has come up kind of talking about how they're
facing issues with pay,
and the non emergency number response
is a bit slow. Is that contributing to
what you're seeing in terms of the kind of
oversaturation of 911 and fire calls that
you're responding to that aren't actual emergencies?
Yes. So the 911 center employs civilian call takers.
The initial call goes to that area.
Those are civilians. And then, depending on the needs of the caller,
whether it's fire medical, then it goes to the fire department.
Any law enforcement need goes to the police department. From there,
our dispatchers the second level
once it gets past the call taker for the fire department are
classified personnel, and we are fully staffed in
that area.
But again, it's more of
a training, and we have to do a better job. We,
the emergency services, need to do a better job of communicating
and an educational approach
for our community on the proper use of the 911 system,
what's an emergency, what would not be considered an emergency, and then provide them the
resources on how else they can get their needs
addressed without necessarily calling 911.
So it's a more comprehensive approach
to that question.
Thank you. Our next virtual speaker is Mr.
Doug Smith.
Can you hear me? Yes.
Great. You just
said you received the top ratings from the two rating agencies, and I've heard in
the past that the fire department is understaffed
and you could use a lot more people. And I'm wondering if
there's a concern that you could possibly lose those ratings
if you don't get the people you need. That's one question.
The second question on page three,
four of your report. It's the statistics, performance measures.
You don't have any response times for
first unit call response times for either
EMS or fire, and I'm wondering why that is.
And also on that page, you talk about EMS incidents
and responses and fire incidents and responses,
and the responses are a lot higher than the incidents,
and I'm curious what the differentiation
is between those two. Okay,
Mr. Smith, you're going to have to repeat the second part of
your question, the first one in regards to staffing,
look, I've made several presentations to the Public Safety Committee.
I made the same presentation last
year regarding when we presented our budget
regarding staffing in 2019 and 2020,
we missed our recruitment target by about 280
firefighters. That was as a result of Proposition B
passing and us having to cancel four academy
classes at that point.
That caused us to miss the recruitment
by 280 firefighters that year. By the time we
started recruitment again, it was 18 months
without hiring a single firefighter.
And in that time, attrition continued.
The normal and annual attrition continued to happen in 2020,
we had higher than normal attrition. So that exacerbated
the issue. Since that time, we've been approved
280 firefighters per year to be hired.
This year, the mayor approved the fifth class,
which puts us at 350 firefighters that we're
going to be hiring this fiscal year. That is,
in attempts to make up for what we lost in 2019 and
2020. Our normal annual attrition is about
170. That's retirements, that's resignations.
That's everything else about 170. We're having to hire
100 above and beyond the normal attrition to try to
make up for what we lost again in 2019 and 2020.
But my most precious resource
is the first year firefighter, because it takes about a year to
get them recruited, to get them trained and get them out into the
stations. So it's a long process, and that's
why it's taken us so long. It's going to take us several fiscal years to
make up what we lost back then.
It is a concern for us. We are making up
that shortage by increasing our
overtime budget numbers in order to bring in
personnel to make up for those shortages.
But the goal is, the strategic goal is to get back up to
full staffing, because at that point, it would allow me to make the
additional ask for more ambulances and more inspectors and
more capacity to be able to service the increased demand.
If you can repeat your have the rating
agencies indicated any concern about the fact that you
are dough as you just described? Doug, is this your second question?
Well, it's related to the question you just answered,
but the second question relates to page
item three four, where you have your performance
measures and you don't have any targets
for first call response for either fire or EMS
in 2023. And then on that same page,
you talk about EMS incidents and responses and
fire incidents and responses, and responses are a
lot higher than the incidents. And I'm just wondering what's
the difference between those two. So the reason for that,
Doug, is we're switching to accreditation measures.
In the past, we were reporting averages.
The average means that half the time you're better, but half the time you're
worse. The accreditation measure now is
based on percentiles. The 90th percentile is what they're measuring.
That gives a better picture
of your capacity and the
type of service you're delivering. That's the reason for that change.
We're also looking at outcome based responses
instead of just simply showing
up in a certain amount of
time and stopping the clock. Again, that's the
reason right now that you're seeing a lot of first
response units, ladder trucks, fire trucks, when you
actually need a medical and EMS transport unit.
We haven't been tracking that appropriately.
We're stopping the clock based on response times without really looking at
the outcome. That is going to provide me
the analysis and the tools to make the case for those
additional units that we desperately need.
I know we need more ambulances. That's the reason that we're sending
the first available unit. A lot of times they show up just
to stop the clock and then they're waiting for that ambulance and
transport unit to arrive minutes later.
The answer to that is not adding more fire
trucks. It's adding more ambulance capacity, which will help the system. It'll improve
the response times for transport and it
really will improve the working environment.
Thank you, Chief. And what about the incidents and
response difference between those two?
What are you looking at?
Doug? I'm going to have to get back to you on that. I don't want
to give you an answer off the fly. I got to see exactly what
you are asking about. And Mrs. Smith, if you want to
submit any additional questions to District E at Houst Gov,
we'll get back to you shortly.
I know and I appreciate it. Thank you all. Thank you.
Thank you. We will now move into the in person
public comment period. Public speakers, please make your way to the
podium after your name is called. We have one in person
speaker. Mr. Butler,
please come forward.
Ms. McHenry, if you could please step back and
he will be able to use your microphone and then you can come back.
Thank you.
Good morning. Good morning. You have two minutes for questions.
Thank you. How are you? How are you, chief? Good to see you.
Mr. Brother, good to see you as well. My name is Broderick Butler and I'm
a resident of Cynic Wood neighborhood in northeast Houston,
which is District B. I'd like to thank the Chief for his leadership.
I have a few questions for him, but first a statement. I want him
to thank Al Bennett, who has made sure that my
community has gotten carbon monoxide detectors and smoke detectors
and continues to do so recently. So my three questions are this.
In a previous budget cycle chief, you mentioned to
this committee that you had a significant number of engines in your fleet that were
in disrepair. You were waiting on new engines,
and you were also seeking to technology,
but you're also waiting to seek more training for
your firefighters. You've addressed these points in some of the questions that were
posed to you today. But again, the theme
is, can you reiterate has any of these
issues been addressed at this point? That's the first question. The second
question is, given that you have five incoming classes
queued up, that's great news, but are you currently having
trouble recruiting applicants within the Houston city limits?
If so, what have you done to combat that? And the thought
is about increasing diversity, as one of the council members
mentioned. And so these themes are sort of repetitive themes,
but my last question actually deals with my specific community as
sort of the other ones overlay, and that is we're
going in hurricane season and how many firehouses in
Northeast? Houston, which is sort of north of
610, east of 59. Specifically the seven 70
116 zip code have
water evacuation and water rescue equipment.
And from what I know, the Tidwell firehouse
has one boat. But my question going forward is,
is there a possibility or opportunity to increase the number of boats
or water rescue equipment and apparatuses that
are in my section of the city?
Mr. Weller, thank you, first of all, for your question and for being here
in person. I know that's important.
All this is important to you. So I wrote down your questions.
I will thank albennett is one of our better
employees, and he's very responsive and he's very committed to what he's doing.
So I'll certainly relay your thanks to him in
regards to the engines and disrepair. Five years ago,
five and a half years ago when I came here,
we had an issue with an aging fleet.
There was no question about that. We had engines that were
essentially catching fire on scene. That was
as a result of the
way they were purchasing these units. They're very expensive.
A fire truck cost us about $600,000 per unit.
A ladder truck is over a million dollars. It's very expensive.
They made a large purchase. They had made a large purchase about
15 years before that, and they
didn't have a comprehensive replacement plan, which meant that
you buy a large purchase of fleet vehicles at one point, and they're great
when they're new, but then they all start aging at the same time and falling
apart at the same time. I'm happy to report that thanks
to the mayor and council and their support, we've replaced
over 50% of the entire fleet in these last five
years. We have a small percentage
that now is outside the ten year expected
lifecycle of these heavy apparatus.
We have begun to focus not only on the
heavy apparatus and ambulances, but we were also focusing
on the light duty vehicles, as we mentioned through some other creative
programs, the lease of these vehicles and outright purchase of
these. So we're making a wholesale replacement
of all apparatus. They're all emergency response apparatus in
my estimation. But in regards to the engines and
the ladder trucks, we have made significant improvements
in the state of this fleet. In addition to that,
the ambulance replacements, we've replaced almost 50% of those
ambulances as well. We are no longer
doing the refurbishing and putting them back into
the system. We're buying turnkey
ambulances, which with all the new safety
features that come with the new apparatus. So that's
a better and safer unit for our firefighters.
So in regards to that, yes, we are
well over 50% of replacement of our entire fleet
in terms of technology. We have made significant investments in that too.
We've replaced all our MDTs and the majority of our apparatus.
We've also switched over our records management system for
our inspectors. Now we're in the in four program. In the
past, they were doing their inspections and documenting on
paper. That's very antiquated, very inefficient. We've made significant
improvements in technology in that respect. Every one of our apparatus,
our heavy apparatus, has a thermal imaging camera. Now, in the
past, that was not the case. So we've provided that in
terms of technology. And so I can point
to a variety of areas where we've made improvements in technology training.
Again, sometimes we can't
get the contributions from the general fund because
of different priorities, but we haven't stopped there. We've looked
for nontraditional funding sources to provide for training and
equipment and health and safety aspects for our firefighters.
In the last five and a half years, we've drawn down almost $11
million of grant funds that are dedicated for
either training or equipment or improvements for health and
safety of our firefighters. So we're making progress in that.
In regards to applicants,
especially for applicants from within the city limits, I completely agree
with you. Matter of fact,
in this last month, I've met with the
superintendent for HISD, the vice superintendent for HISD,
and we're looking at a program to be able to recruit individuals
right out of high school. The requirement for
24 credit hours of college hasn't
changed. But what we do know is that there are a lot of students,
and according to their numbers, there are about 6000 students every year that graduate with
an equivalent of 24 credit hours that come from
AP classes or come from other
early college courses that right now
we hadn't been capturing. My goal is to be able to
go directly into these communities that are underrepresented
in our department and recruit directly from high
school onto this organization.
When they graduate, they have choices. Some of them go to college,
some of them go to the military, some go to work. I want to be
another choice for those where we can provide a career for
these individuals and they have the opportunity to serve in their communities.
So we are looking at that, and I agree with you. Our department should be
representative of the communities that we serve. That has been a
focus of mine. If you see our demographics, we've made
huge improvements in recruitment of more minorities
into the fire department. And there
we did some things. We made some changes that just increased the number of qualified
applicants. The standards haven't changed. Okay. But if
we can have a bigger pool of applicants, then we can be more selective as
far as who can come in. We're not having any trouble filling
the classes that we have for the academy.
We have had some challenges, especially during the Pandemic, where we
had to do remote learning in classes via virtually,
because getting a certification for an EMT
is not the virtual approach is not conducive to
that. The curriculum is very challenging.
They need the in class tuition,
so our attrition rate there has been higher than normal. We're hoping that has
changed. Council has approved us getting additional
resources and buildings at the train academy to be able to provide
that training. So we're hoping that that changes for
the better in regard to hurricane season and the assets.
When I got here in 2017, we had Harvey. We didn't have any
high water vehicles. Matter of fact, we had one, and that was from District
A, and we got that vehicle the day that Harvey made
landfall. Since then, we've made
tremendous progress. Now we have 15 high water vehicles
that are spread out throughout the city. We've replaced
our boats. Those are all serviceable. We have an
80 member water strike team that is now trained and equipped and
ready to deploy and augment for these
resources for these incidents. And we've
also made partnerships.
We've used our network with other departments to be able
to meet the training requirements and to be
able to scale up if required. One example
is we've partnered with Public Works.
Do you know how many people fit in the back of a dump truck?
38. Yes, I do. Yes,
sir. And the reason we know that is because we've used those in the past,
but now we've incorporated them into the Cat system.
So if we expect a hurricane
or some inclement weather, we will deploy resources from
Public Works in other areas into our fire stations, and they'll
have a firefighter assigned to them to be able to manage
and be an additional asset in addition to what
we have. So we have made tremendous strides in
that respect as well. In these short five years.
The resources are spread out throughout the city.
Okay. And that is a tactical decision,
but they're deployable anywhere in the city. Okay.
Shift. Absolutely.
One is that we can't put all the resources in one area because
there may not be enough room. But we do know, and based on
what we anticipate, as far as if there's a certain area that we're more
concerned about, then we will shift resources and pre deploy them
to a little bit closer. But those resources are
city of Houston resources, the fire department's resources. It doesn't mean that
they belong to a certain district. We keep them in certain areas,
but we can deploy them and shift as needed.
So my only concern at this point is hopefully the council sees
the benefit of scaling you up compared to the county
scaling up the sheriff's department so that you can actually stand
in the breach if and when and really not if,
when the next natural disaster hits our city that
has to deal with water rescue. Right. Well,
look, again, we welcome
those additional resources,
but we are certainly also reaching out to
other response agencies to have a
unified front and in response to our community's
needs. We work very well with the Houston Police Department.
We work very well with the Harris County Sheriff's Department.
We work very well with Public Works and all other city departments.
We have a good network of personnel
that train together. We're familiar
with each other's capabilities and the resources that we can come to bring
to bear in case we need it, because I think that's a more efficient way
of meeting the expected risk of this community
strategic partnership. Absolutely. And the key is to have those
partnerships in place before the disaster happens.
Thank you very much. If we have
any additional questions, you can always share those at District E, at Houst,
gov. Ms. McHenry, did you have
anything additional that you would like to speak on that we have
not covered? Okay. Well, chief, I want to thank you and
your entire department for the tremendous presentation and the tremendous job you all
do on a daily basis to keep Houstonian safe. As a
council, we are very much appreciative of all that
you do and all of the contributions that you make. So to you and your
entire team, thank you very much. Thank you. Council Member
there are no additional in person speakers before we adjourn.
Please note, budget workshops will continue next week, starting Monday,
May 16 through Thursday, May 19.
Reminder to council members to be checking SharePoint for uploaded
presentations as well as responses for any questions and
submitted. Thank you again to everyone for being here, and this
meeting is adjourned.